I'm really excited today to introduce
a new friend of mine, Korean mccanlis.
She's the sister of literary
icon, Christopher McCandless. Uh,
and she consulted to closely with Jon
Krakauer on his bestselling book into the
wild, which came out in 1996. I'm sure a
lot of you've heard of it or read it. Um,
she also works as a direct advisor,
writer and script contributor to Sean
Penn on his film adaptation of end of the
wild, which was released in 2007. Um,
Korean wrote her own memoir about the
experience called the wild truth, ah,
that was released in November,
2014 and very quickly became both the New
York Times and national bestseller, uh,
and it was followed by international
publications in seven countries and still
counting the wild truth was selected
for many best books of 2014 lists,
including those chosen by readers
and editors at Newsweek, vanity fair,
Amazon and Indy. Next. So it's
a pleasure to introduce Corinne
[inaudible].
Hi,
thank you all for hosting me here today.
I'll keep things pretty casual.
I've got my journal.
Everyone should always write
in a journal every day.
I had to put a
markers and mine of the Google
color, you know, in your logo to her.
Remind me where in the journal I needed
to go back to. So anyway, I'm gonna I,
I'm used to doing very,
very long and formal presentation.
So I've got my journal here to help me
stay on point because I really would like
to get some time at the end of this
to get into Q and a with you guys. Um,
so when I was 21,
I lost my best friend.
He was awesome.
My brother, um, he was 24 when he died
and many of you know the story,
his name was Chris McCandless.
He had graduated with
honors from Emory university
and
that was the last time that
I had ever seen him alive.
Just the last time I'd spoken with
him, he had written me letters. Um,
but I hadn't spoken to him
since seeing him at graduation.
Two years later,
his body was found in this abandoned bus
in the middle of the Alaskan wilderness.
Okay.
There was a lot of mystery surrounding
his death and everything that had
happened during those two years.
And the story of that time and all of
the adventures that he had during that
time
became known as into the wild as such,
um,
summarized the incredible
book written by Jon Krakauer
and it
was also developed into a film by Sean
Penn. And Chris's story really became,
I mean,
John's book was so popular,
it's published in over 30 languages.
Um,
Shawn's movie also, so beautiful.
And Chris's story reached even
more of a global audience,
but it wasn't the whole story.
So to give you a little backstory,
this is Chris with the Shanandoah
behind him. We used to hike a lot.
This is my hiking hat,
um,
in that area.
And he loves to be out in nature.
Chris always said to me that nature
may be harsh and it's honesty,
but it never lies to you.
Okay.
And he felt,
I don't know,
he felt whole, like he felt
real when he was out in nature.
And,
um,
I just remembered it was always
his favorite place to be.
It was an always an escape for him.
Even at this young age,
Chris and I were very close.
He was always my protector.
I heard it's a cute picture. Right?
All right. This picture tells a story.
This picture was taken
on a typical morning.
Our house was
on an everyday basis filled
with domestic violence,
and this day was not unlike any other.
The violence had erupted over the
breakfast table and continued on until my
parents realized that it was time
for church. It was Easter Sunday.
So we were putting into our best suit
and dress and we were marched into the
backyard for pictures.
And
you know,
pictures,
they catch an image in time,
right?
But you don't really know what's going on.
You don't know the whole
story behind the image. And
whenever we would have to pause for
the perfect little family pictures.
MMM.
Our Dad would be by hand a camera
screaming at us. Smile, smile.
So what we had just been through in
the household, really not in the mood,
but you had to do it. If you
didn't. I knew what was coming next.
Now look closely at our
expressions in these pictures.
So I'm being compliant.
We've got a smile on my face,
I've got my hand behind his back.
I'm trying to convince Chris,
you know, smile, let's get this done
and look at the look on his face.
If you really look closely, you know
he's only about six years old here,
but he's already over that
he already understands.
Now what's really important
about this picture,
I've got it on the cover of my book
because people look at that and like, oh,
that's such a sweet picture.
But again,
it's the point of the story behind
the images that we see, right?
That's what this whole talk
is going to be about and
hm,
you know, I can remember like, like it
was yesterday. It's, it's, you have this,
this image that you're going
to portray out to society,
but sometimes it's so very different
from what is actually going on.
So
Chris, just even at that age, he wasn't
going to accept that he was already
planning.
He was already at that young age making
a determination of what's right and
what's wrong. When you grow up in
a household of domestic violence,
you become acclimated to it.
You don't know at this age that
every household isn't like that.
You don't understand.
So you know when,
when your environment is saturated with
that you become completely desensitized
to it.
Chris understood something was wrong.
Now as
we grew up, you know, in a lot of
ways Chris was your typical kid,
but in other ways there was
just something about him that,
I don't know,
you could say it was deeper than most
people at that age and sometimes we would
just have be having typical
kid conversations or where
we'd be fighting over,
you know, that's my space or don't come
in my room. But other times, you know, he,
we'd be having these conversations about
an author or something that he just
read that he wanted me
to read or you know,
big questions and I was more interested
in stuffed animals at that age or makeup
at a later age. Chris was different. Um,
at this age,
he was already thinking a lot about
okay,
who he wanted to be and probably most
importantly, who he would not become.
So
John's book became,
were required reading into the wild,
became required reading at about 3000
high schools and colleges across the
United States.
John doesn't like to do public speaking,
so he would suggest me, and
it took me a very, very,
very long time to get to the point where
I felt comfortable going and speaking
to people about Chris's story.
And
when I did, I would be talking to
students who are about the sage.
This is Chris's typical senior
picture in high school. Right.
And when I came to the school,
you would see a change
in the students because
it became real to them. You know,
it was no longer just an assignment.
It was this lesson because this is a real
flesh and blood sister of this person.
And
it wasn't just that I could see
that they were inspired by Chris.
There's usually two camps.
Some people admired him for what he did.
Some people admonished him.
That's part of the reason that it's
something that's that's assigned, right?
Because they want people to get into
that critical kind of thinking and think
outside of themselves.
But
what hit me more was that
I never left one school.
First of all, they would always
ask about the backstory, right?
Which at first I wasn't necessarily
talking about, but in the Q and a,
that's always what the questions were.
Why was he so angry with your parents?
Why did he leave the way he did?
Why didn't he talk to anybody for those
years after he left college and when I
opened up,
you know,
and the safety of the intimate walls
of a classroom where things weren't
recorded yet.
I saw this change come over the students
and some in particular because I never
left one school and still to this day,
all the years that I've been speaking,
I've never left one school, one
university, a corporate event.
I've never left anywhere where at
least one person didn't come up.
And in this case it was these high school
students that didn't come up and ask
for help for the very first time
because they were going
through a similar experience.
And here was someone talking about it.
So
after years of of doing this and
seeing this everywhere I went,
I realize what a disservice I had done
to my brother and not just to Chris,
but those who would read about him and
be inspired by him because Chris always
said there is nothing more
important than the truth.
And John did an incredible book,
a incredible job writing into the wild
and what was left out of it is my fault
because I want to John to understand.
But I wouldn't let him write that.
MMM.
I wasn't ready. And I
realized later on, wow,
what did a service had been done to such
an incredible writer and someone with
that journalistic style of Jon
Krakauer to give them information.
But tell them beforehand, I'm going to
tell you something, but my condition is,
you're not allowed to reveal this.
I just need you to know.
I didn't think anybody was
going to read into the wild.
So it was kind of John's fault.
Um,
so anyway,
I realize why a disservice I had done
by not talking about this and here,
20 years has passed. So you
know, as I mentioned earlier,
I journal all the time.
Chris is the one that taught me to journal
and we'll get a little bit more into
that.
But I just started writing and all those
journal entries turned into a book.
And
what I didn't expect was
for my book to start a new
conversation about domestic violence.
There were all these blanks and Chris's
story and people rightfully so had
filled in those blanks with
their own answers, you know,
as to why he had left the way he did
or what had happened with the family.
And
when my book came out,
or long before the book came out,
just when I was in these rooms
of 50 people, 500 people,
it didn't matter. When I would
talk about the rest of the story,
it forced people to take
another look at Chris's story,
not in defense of him
because in all fairness, he,
he didn't live his life worried about
what anyone else was going to think about
him. He was concerned about what
he thought about himself, but
now that people had the rest
of the answers, a lot of
their perspectives changed.
And that was not something that I realized
when I was 21 years old and he was
gone and I was having to tell
this journalist
why he left.
So
people not only would take
another look at Chris's story,
but they started taking another look
at story in their own communities.
And I started doing the same thing.
So whenever I was,
um,
at these schools,
and you know, for the most part, these
are, if they're hiring a speaker to come,
um,
these schools are filled with kids who
have a certain amount of privilege right
there. Um, they're all
wearing pretty nice clothes.
When I pull up to speak, there's, you
know, tons of cars in the parking lot.
So pretty much all these kids have
access to cars to drive for school. Um,
they all have phones, right?
Computers and tablets.
So they all want to connect
with me on social media.
And I've never really been big on
having a social media presence. My, um,
my publisher is so incredibly
kind and patient with me for not,
you're really supposed to be on the
lot and I'm not. Um, but you know,
I do try and make an effort and for the
most part it's when I'm connecting with
these students because I want
to stay connected with them.
I want to see what they're,
what they're doing.
I want to see what they're
doing with their lives.
I want to hear what they're doing next
because they'll tell me their stories.
They'll tell me how they were inspired
by Chris and what they want to do.
But as I am looking at the social media
of these kids that I've connected with,
and these are good kids,
I'm also seeing all these other stories,
right?
That also good kids,
but all these other pages and
connections that populate, right?
So I don't have to tell you I'm a Google,
but you know,
you're looking at social media and then
someone else has commented and then
that's curious. So I'm going to click
on that. I'm gonna look on that. Oh,
I think that kid might've been at
the lecture. Let me look at that.
So I started
to connect more and more into the social
media and with this age group and in
paying more attention to what
I saw through them, their
friends, their classmates,
I really began to see
something that concerned me.
Um, there was a lot of good,
but there was also a lot of bad.
And to me it appeared that what I
considered to be a negative influence and,
uh, negative stimuli, it was
quite out of whack. You know,
if you look at the balance,
um,
and what I could see was,
you know,
there's so much stimuli
and reality becomes a blur.
There's just so much going on and
that's what I want to get into.
Um, some of the things that I started to
see, so I just grabbed some screenshots.
I,
I would look at pages of students that
I connected with across the country,
but I also took a closer look in my
own community. So I started looking at,
you know,
easy search,
a name of your kid or
your kids' friends or,
um, all of these kids that go to
the high schools around the area.
And these are some of
the things that I saw.
So here's one that's got a
few pictures and it says,
grab your girl like this,
right? And it's got,
I don't know what Emoji
that is a funny crying face.
And then it's got the hearts right.
Smiley face with the hearts.
It's got to have a name.
I know what that emojis called,
but now let's take a closer look at
these four photos that they have.
So it would be deal, right? Don't be an
overprotective mom. That's not a big deal,
right? It's just a little, nothing
graphic. So there's three of these shots,
I guess. It's cool that they have
cigarettes, whatever. All right.
And then this is the fourth one.
When I saw that, I found that
shocking. Grab your girl like this.
What I found more shocking was,
and let's go back,
maybe it's on here. Okay, let's see.
There's 14 now. This is, I'm
watching these things in real time.
So this goes up and then I'm watching
it over a matter of, you know,
that day there's 1400
kinda sucks getting old.
I need my reading glasses.
1400 retweets.
And what?
1372 likes.
What is there to like about, about
this? What is there to like about that?
All right.
So then I started looking and seeing,
looking at more things and um,
I saw this theme and this pattern
that caused me a lot of concern.
So here's just another one.
Okay?
So this is a meme,
right? They called mean.
So here's a skeleton getting
ready to punch a baby.
And it says this, this is how infants
are killed during an abortion.
Now I'm not here to talk about
abortion rights or anything like that.
That's a whole nother topic,
right?
But I think it's fair to say that
both sides of that issue could agree
that this is inappropriate. This
is a skeleton. Cold cocking a baby.
Okay.
And again,
you've got,
uh, let's see, 2100 retweets,
almost 3,500 favorites.
Now, the majority of what I'm seeing,
these are school aged kids, right?
These are teenagers. This
meme, the mentality to me,
it, they're so separated
from reality. You know,
it's like everything's a cartoon.
It's not real,
but that's a real issue.
Right?
And they don't know the intent of the
person that drew this beam or posted it.
Right. Are they saying that this is,
are they, do they think abortion is,
is fair? It's a writer day or
they're against it. They don't know.
I started to interview these kids,
right?
I started talking to the kids
in groups and I started saying,
and I'd show these things
and I would say, why? Why?
Why would you show this?
And they literally would like,
they know it's supposed to be bad,
but they kind of have to
cover their face or writers.
I think it's just thought it was funny.
What about that is funny?
And I would say, uh, okay.
And I would name the person that I
blocked out that, that said this.
Do you know who that person is?
No.
Hmm.
So you don't know what their intent is
behind this. Is this a real picture?
I don't know. How would you
like it if that was your sister?
And they're horrified that someone sister,
you don't know what the intent is
of the person that posted this yet.
You are readily reposting it.
And that's what I mean by this.
Just constant stimuli. They see
something. Oh Haha. And there were,
you know its peers. Everybody's
retweeting, everybody's
liking. So they do a two,
they don't even know why they're doing it.
They don't think about the effect.
They don't think about the intent,
the messages that society
spreads are so important.
Okay.
And through social media we are willingly
and incessantly spreading messages
without knowing what the
intent of that message is.
Okay.
So you know,
it's like that noise of society.
And when you talk about
mmm
purpose and everything that you do,
that intent is so important.
So
when you aren't listening to yourself
and you lose that self awareness,
you lose that accountability for what
you're doing with your own actions.
So up to this, it leads me
to contradiction, right?
A lot of times if you're not
thinking about what you're doing,
a lot of times you do
contradictory things.
This is a 17 year old girl
that posted this, right?
Am I just an overprotective mother?
Right? Am I just like someone who think,
oh my God, if that was my daughter,
like it's not graphic, right? I mean,
there's ads for underwear that
aren't that different than that.
But look what it says.
If we date
with the Emoji with the tongue,
yeah.
But look at, this is her favorites.
Look at the post right before it,
the new Steven Universe episode,
uh,
was about sexual harassment.
This show is so important.
So she's telling people this
is so important and let's see,
there's five likes of that.
Yet the very next thing she
favorites is this photograph.
And she writes,
if we date and there's 349
retweets and 562 likes,
it's completely contradictory.
And I have to say that,
um, you know, it's not,
it's not that untypical.
Here's another one. A,
if she stuck your fingers keeper,
she nasty.
I mean,
oh
yeah, there's a hell of a Lada
retweets and likes of that one.
So these are just your
typical teenage kids.
These are not these trouble making kids.
And all my kid would never do that.
These, I know who these
kids are, they're good kids,
but it's just they become
desensitized to this, right?
And it leads to more and
more and more problems. So,
and while I'm picking on the kids,
I got to say,
adults too oftentimes are no better.
So we will have,
um,
an NFL player that gets filmed in
an elevator hitting a woman, right?
We will have a politician that
gets caught for sexual harassment.
We will have, um, news anchors,
celebrities, same thing happens, you know,
and sometimes they get away with it.
Sometimes the hammer falls,
they lose their jobs, right? And so women,
we as women stand up and we say,
we are not going to accept this behavior.
This is wrong.
It is wrong for women to
not be treated fairly,
right? We want a demand fair treatment.
We want an end to sexual harassment.
We want an end to an abuse
of power and control.
Did you refixed shades of gray yet?
Yeah.
Oh, let's read it for a book club and
then we'll go see the movie together.
It's a total contradiction.
It's a complete contradiction.
This is the message that we're sending
to our daughters and to the boys that
they will date.
So this leads me to
anybody read this book yet?
Jon Krakauer Missoula
heard of it before. Okay. How many of
you have heard of 50 shades of grey?
Okay. So, um,
if you have a child going to college,
you have got to make them read this book.
This should be the Fye book for
every student going into college.
Um, John does not need my help selling
ebooks and I'm not doing that for this.
This was because I believe in this.
My 18 year old will not go to college
without reading this book, um,
college or not wherever
they go. So Missoula, um,
John and his journalistic style
investigates the campus rape culture.
And I am not asked to go speak to any
colleges anymore without addressing the
issue of sexual violence. Every
college I go to, they want me to,
to merge that into my talk.
It is a huge issue.
But look at some of the things we just
saw on social media and it goes back to
self awareness and
accountability in John's.
The overwhelming majority of these cases
are you have a young man in a young
woman and
in the overwhelming majority there
were highly intoxicated when this event
happened.
So there's interviews and you know,
intercourse happened and somebody thought
that it was consensual and the other
person didn't think it is,
but they know that they blacked out
and the other person blacked out too.
And so piecing that all
together is difficult.
And it goes back to what I tried to talk
to students about is self awareness is
not just what's my purpose in life and
what am I going to do with my career?
It's being aware of your
space in your time right now,
where you are,
what you're doing,
and if you have control of your
intent and do others around,
you have control of theirs.
To me so much
goes back to,
yeah,
in an instance like this, there's
this controversy of truth, right?
What's the truth?
And
there'll be controversy about that,
but is it getting enough
attention for the right reasons?
It brings me back to the
influences surrounding these
students that are on their
way to college.
Um,
let me give you a little
bit of levity. As I was, uh,
on my book tour,
not long after John's book had come out.
Um,
I go into a bookstore and,
um, I'm always looking to see what books
are out there and I'm looking at John's
books and John has several bestsellers
and you usually see a few copies.
And then I also happen to see Charles
Krauthammer's book and I liked him and I
picked it up. And, uh, I'm
on a long layover in Chicago,
so I'm reading the chapter that he
entitles, uh, in defense of the f word,
which is brilliant by the way. Um, so
I'm looking at that, but as I'm reading,
I'm standing there reading and
I'm distracted. I'm like, what?
You know, something that's catching
my eye peripherally. And it was boobs.
It was a big set of boobs.
Okay.
Everyone knows who that is,
right?
So there's like three copies
of John's book, Missoula.
There's a few copies of Charles Commerce,
like 50 copies of this book.
Okay.
And this is Kim Kardashians book
entitled it's her book of selfies.
And No, I'm not trying to
harp on Kim or anything.
I'm just saying let's use this as an
example cause she certainly doesn't mind
putting it out there. Um, there's like
50 copies of this book on the shelf.
The book's entitled,
Selfish.
And why does the bookstore
have so many of her copies?
It's a big book too. I mean, you're
in an airport bookstore. It's heavy.
Why are there so many
copies and that shelf?
Because they know they're going
to sell them. It's society.
And while I was looking up to
find this cover, I found this one,
which I thought was hilarious.
Kim Kardashians. Shellfish.
That's it. That was, that was a brilliant,
um, all right, let me bring things back.
Okay.
So this,
this just brings me back to the
influence surrounding teenagers,
right?
Um,
and not just kids of this age,
but little kids because the
little brothers and sisters
have kids these age want
to be just like them. They can't wait to
get their, their iPhones, their androids.
I can't wait to get their phones right.
And that's what they see all the time.
They are very aware of what
the teenagers are doing.
Um,
does anyone know this is
someone in particular?
Does anyone know who this is?
Anybody recognize?
Okay. And I take this around to, you know,
I've taken this around to a lot of
students in different schools all over the
country.
Almost nobody knows who this
person is lately though,
everybody knows who this person is.
Okay?
Right? I know some of you are, which
is when, now what if I said, uh,
cash me outside? How about dad? Right?
You know who that is because
it's all over the Internet.
So I didn't know who it was,
but when on Saturday I
had my littlest girl,
my daughter, my youngest daughter
at a Ukulele lessons and he said,
hey, you're speaking at Google on
Tuesday, aren't you? And I said, yeah.
And I told them what the title
of my talk was going to be. Um,
the socialization of domestic violence,
um,
diluting a devastating
influence. And he says, Oh yeah,
I was a, he teaches at the academy rock.
And so he's got a group of students,
he goes in one day and they're all joking
saying, cash me outside. How about dad?
He says, what are you speaking
English? What are you saying?
So then they tell them and they pull
out their phones and they show him,
look at this girl, this is hilarious.
And He's thinking, oh my gosh.
Well,
so he starts telling me about this
person and come to find out she's got,
well,
she was on Dr Phil and I watched the
video on youtube and during the video she
threatens to beat the audience up.
That's what the cash me outside.
How about that is she's going
to beat the audience up.
Her mother translated and um,
and then she got up and she got up in
her mother's face and she was threatening
to beat up her mom.
Okay.
This girl apparently now has endorsement.
She's signed a contract
for a reality show.
Let's see how many views are on
this five and a half million views.
Right.
This is the other,
it's a mixture.
This is Jack and Draka. I'm hoping I'm
saying his last name right. I met him. Um,
he probably won't remember me,
but I definitely remembered him.
I met him at an Fye conference.
Both of our books were featured as books.
Um, do we use it as required
reading at colleges?
And he presented,
and this is a young teenage genius.
He's now at Stanford class of 2019.
Who invented
an early did. He invented a, uh,
I don't even have the time
to explain it all properly,
but he developed a test
at a very economical tasks
that's an early detector for
pancreatic cancer cause he lost someone
in his life to pancreatic cancer that
was very dear to him.
He's also invented a water bottle that,
that these expensive ones that
we buy at the sports stores,
but something that can be manufactured
for pennies on the dollar compared to
others and can be sent to these third
world countries where people don't have
access to clean water and they can
go and scoop up this water that's not
drinkable and they can drink.
So He's, he's saving lives.
He's changing the world.
None of the teenagers know who this is.
Here's Jack's Ted talk.
It's got 304,000 views.
That's pretty good.
Okay.
She's got five and a half million views.
Doesn't mean that they are approving
of it, but that saturation,
that's influential because whereas some
of these kids might kind of laugh at her
and talk about how she, you know,
they also are thinking, wow, she's,
she's made all that money.
I mean, they're human.
That's the kind of things
that they think about.
Kids think about shoes and they want
the range rover like somebody else has.
So let's see. Here's her Danielle
or goalie, I guess her name.
Here's her Twitter page.
She's got 340 no,
I'm sorry,
243,000 followers and she just joined
February of 2017 so just a couple of
months. She's got that many
followers. Here's Jack's page.
He joined in July of 2011
okay.
He's got just under 22,000 followers.
Here's his Instagram page.
He's got 3,400 followers.
He's probably had it up for several years.
Here's her Instagram page.
9.2 million,
9.2 million followers,
which means when these kids go and scroll,
the latest video that she posted bragging
about bullying people and beating up
kids and stealing cars.
Yeah,
there's only 3,400 that are learning
about Jack's latest invention that's going
to change this world.
But what did we as a society,
why?
Why does everybody not know who this is?
Why do they know who she is?
You know? You don't have to
be intentionally searching
for something negative,
but it's so saturated that
that's what's out there.
Now,
I'm not saying that there isn't also
good that comes with the exposure,
right? I mean, this is, technology
has been a wonderful thing.
So here's an organization, no more.org,
right? They've been fantastic.
I've spoken all around the country at
groups and a lot of times they're related
in some way to this group and support.
I've spoken at New Beginnings and Seattle,
a center for women in
transition in Michigan. Um,
the women's home in Texas Samaritan
House where I live in Virginia,
um, Shelter House, the barn
outside of DC. There's,
there's organizations all over the country
that are working to prevent domestic
and sexual violence and they're out there.
But this group has 55,000 followers,
55,000 followers compared
to nine Portola hills. See,
let's be fair. Let's, that was
her Instagram page. Instagram.
They have 29 almost 30,000
followers compared to what was hers,
9.2 million.
There's something wrong with that
and I don't have all the answers, but I
know there's something wrong with that.
This is the kind of thing that concerns
me because it's out of balance.
I care about it because
I'm worried for these kids
who see domestic violence every day and
have become acclimated to it and don't
understand it's wrong.
I worry for these kids. These are
my girls, Heather and Christiana.
I love that picture. They're little.
They're, or they're bigger now,
so they don't like when
I showed that picture,
Heather thinks that she doesn't look good
without makeup and that her hair's too
curly.
So here's another picture of Heather.
So you know, I worry about this as a
mom, I worry about this as an advocate.
I worry about this as a community member,
but I also worry about this
as a sister
because am desperate
to know that we have as a human
race that we have learned something.
Okay?
In the past 25 years,
it's been 25 years,
but
I don't have the power and I don't have
all the answers, right? I'm one person.
There's a lot of advocates
all over the country
who does have the power.
I think you guys have the power.
We're at freaking Google.
All right. What's a Google?
Google is is like the highest
number you can get. Right?
10 to the hundredth power. I'm
not a mathematician. I googled it.
These pages that populate these,
these recommendations that come up,
somebody is programming all that stuff.
Somebody is creating that some of the
most brilliant minds are in this a hundred
plus set of buildings.
Why can't we come up with a way that
that helps with a better balance?
I'm not talking about censorship,
I'm talking about balance. I'm talking
about educating these young people.
Okay,
there's gotta be a way to do it
and I challenge you guys to
come up with those answers.
So I think that can bring
us into the Q and. A.
You guys have everyone's
attention every day.
You and companies like yours have
everyone's attention every day.
So what can you do to
help with this balance?
Okay,
so what I take away from, from hearing
you talk and reading your book is that
in his own way, Chris and his
time when he was coming of age,
was frustrated by a lot of the
things you've just mentioned.
Maybe not Instagram and Twitter back then,
but
that didn't exist back then.
Exactly. That's one of my points.
Like students will say to me,
why don't you just pissed that
he didn't send you a text?
You didn't hear from him for two years.
He didn't even send you an email
and I hold up my phone and I say,
we now have these back then and they think
she looks amazing for being 200 years
old. I mean, they don't. It's it's,
they can't comprehend it.
That's like trying to explain to
someone that there no oxygen in the air.
They can't comprehend that.
That's why to me,
these all these things aren't
necessarily real to them.
Right.
They're clicking and favoriting
and reposting without
really thinking about what
they're doing.
No. If I may, that's a
great transition road.
This is what I was getting at is in
both John's book and in your book,
you do a great job of
about how Chris was just,
you began to talk with how Chris was a
little different even at age six. Right.
He was more aware than most.
Right. He, he cared about authenticity.
He had principles and, and,
and you described him as being unique
in that way. You and your book,
you say even even friends would say
your brother is a little intense.
Not in a bad way,
but he's intense.
It's what I wonder is if
you fast forward to today,
it is still the norm for people
to click on cash me outside.
How about that instead of
the book here. Thank you. Uh,
let's be fair enough.
Fair enough.
It's still the norm for people to be
attracted to that and not to stand up in
the way that Chris did. So
what I wonder is, is is,
is do you have thoughts free for students
that you speak to around the how and
why they can be more authentic?
Some of it's entertainment, right? You
have students who are going through these,
you know,
calculus classes and did they
necessarily want to think that much?
And so part of it's entertainment,
but there has to be some responsibility
and accountability because you can't
tell me that seeing that and that being
so saturated and not just that it's
being rewarded by adults.
It's not other kids that
gave her a reality show.
Right.
So kids see that that's,
that's what I'm talking about is,
is that kind of responsibility
and accountability?
I probably didn't answer your question.
No, no, no. There's, there's no easy
answer to how do you solve this,
this right truth of society.
But I think one thing you talk a lot about
is his parenting and how Christen you
both, uh, it's beautiful. In your book,
you described the lessons you learned
about how you want to do things
differently than your parents did,
for example.
Yeah. My parents weren't all
bad. I mean, they weren't.
And I talk about that and I flush it out
in, in my book, they taught us some, some
hard work ethics and a
lot of good things too.
But you have to decide what you're going
to emulate and what you're not. And,
and specifically on the
issue of domestic violence,
breaking that cycle is very important
thing and it's not easy to do.
And so in that same
vein, it seems, you know,
you talk about some examples with your
own daughters of how you've tried to
embody authenticity. Um, you know,
positive thoughts around relationships
and around relationship with the self.
I know a lot of parents are either in
this room or watching on live stream.
Do you have any thoughts or tips or I
how to embody these values and your own
family for you?
Sure. And you know, Gosh, I'm not,
I'm not standing up here like, Hey,
I'm doing it right and everybody's got to
get on board. No, no, no, no, no, no. My,
my 18 year old, I love her.
She is such a good kid. She is.
I have an 18 year old daughter that's
never rolled her eyes at me and my
presence or slammed the door.
Right.
Miracle is it because I'm such an
amazing parent. I'd like the thing.
So she's probably not going to say that,
you know,
but let's take that for example,
she,
I know I take my kids to my events and
sometimes things thinking and sometimes
they don't.
My oldest,
she came up from the basement one night
I was sitting working at the kitchen
table and she came up and I might get
off tangent, you can reel me back in.
But she came up from watching a
TV show, just blubber. I mean,
she was crying so hard
that she couldn't speak.
And I get, I'm like, yeah,
oh my God, I have her. What's the
matter? What happened? What's wrong?
I don't remember the name glow.
She just, I'm like, oh, she's
watching the walking dead.
I've never watched the show.
Maybe I shouldn't be letting
my cue watch that show.
I don't, you know, but she
is beyond herself with grief.
Genuinely. She's a smart
kid and I say, honey,
first of all, he didn't die. Like I hear
you talk about this guy all the time.
I know people that write scripts.
This guy didn't die. Okay,
this is the last show of the
season. Trust me. Oh, he didn't die.
They just want you to think sober.
So,
but she could not connect.
She's smart,
but they're so disconnected from reality.
Like it affected her so much and it's
easier to connect the things like that.
Now when I talked to her about real
things that are happening in the world,
in these terrible tragedies,
she doesn't have the same reaction.
I mean, maybe part of it is a
defense mechanism. You know,
it's not that she doesn't concern
about those things, but it's,
that is, that's not good
that that happened, you know,
but it's not this and, and so, you know,
it bewilders me sometimes, but
when it comes to parents, right,
I say maybe I shouldn't let her watch
that show now I think it's okay for her to
watch that show.
Um,
it's probably something I
should have watched so I
could make that determination.
Um, but I, I, you know,
I talk with other parents about these
issues and I'll mention how I found
Heather posting something inappropriate.
And so I took her phone away
for six months and I get this,
you took your daughter's phone. You
know, I could never do that. Oh my God,
she would hate me. My kid would hate
me. Like, well, your kid's 12. I mean,
and I'm not judging other parents.
Everyone has their own things going on,
but it goes back to this
accountability and responsibility.
I mean you have to be willing to,
to my advice to parents,
you have to be willing to not be their
best friend because you have to be their
parents first. Yeah. And later in life,
hopefully they'll realize that you were
their best friend and really looking out
for them.
But,
but we all survived without phones
and computers and we were that agent.
So you have to, you know, and,
and, and I, my advice to students,
you know,
every time I'm talking with,
I always hold up my journal and
I asked them how many people,
how many people in this room journal?
Okay.
I always say everybody should journal
even if it's one or two sentences. And I,
and I don't do it every night.
Sometimes I'm too exhausted.
But the good thing about journal,
and I always say you do it
with a real paper and a pen.
Why do you think it's
with a real paper and pen?
They want to go to their devices,
right? But if you go to your device,
you're going to be bombarded by all
this stuff. Some good, a lot bad.
And that's the noise, this noise
of society. What are your thoughts?
What are you thinking?
Get away from all the influence and figure
out what your place is in this world.
What you want to do.
For sure.
You talk about your brother being your
protector all the time in and you see it
in the picture. Do you see
it in the stories share in
the book? And I wondered if,
if his inclination to think about these
deep things at a young age was in part
because he was a protector for you.
He was in a way,
I think trying to self parents a bit and
provide some positive influence in your
life and help you as well.
And so he was taking that
responsibility at a young age,
younger than most people are comfortable.
And now you're encouraging kids to journal
and do what Chris did in taking some
accountability responsibility
for their own selves.
But you're also talking about
parents and we're thinking, what,
what I hear you saying is parents,
it might suck if your
daughter hates you for a day,
but that's your kid fair a week,
however long it takes. Right.
But I hear you're saying to parents,
take some responsibility to have that
difficult conversation instead of just
batting your eye or looking
at looking at another way.
We all need to be more responsible.
Is that what you're saying?
Right. And I'm not, yeah, I don't,
I'm not stellar at all of this myself.
We, I put we in this and including me. Um,
you know, it's tough for
parents of, you know, my,
I'm 45 years old and I updated
some apps the other day.
I have no clue how the hell
they use these things now.
But my 11 year old could pick up my
phone and intuitively just figure it out,
you know? So a lot of times when I
talked to parents about social media,
they, ah, I don't even
understand how all that works.
Some of them have the attitude of, you
know what, you just got to trust your kid.
You just got it.
But they are aware of a lot of the things
that are happening and the things that
those kids are exposed to. Sure. Um,
so you have to be willing to have
the uncomfortable conversations.
You have to be willing to take the phone.
You have to be unfortunately
willing to learn how snapchat works.
Um, you do if you're going to
give them the access to it. Right.
You gotta be willing to say,
but let me make a point here about Chris.
You said that, that I encourage
kids to do what Chris did.
Chris died out in the
middle of the wilderness.
So I encourage, you know, people tell me,
I get messages from people all over the
world and people say that your brother
changed my life.
And
I see where Chris Inspires people
to,
to make
positive changes in their lives.
But when someone tells me and they come
to me and they're in tears and they say,
your brother saved my life,
I say to them,
Chris died in 1992
he couldn't do that for you.
Now he can be a spark that lights a
fuel in you to do that for yourself,
but own it. You did that for
yourself. Yeah. And that, you know,
that's so,
so yeah,
I want people to be influenced by Chris's,
his desire to have a purpose in life.
Right?
He died so young, but he's
influenced so many people, um,
without even trying to, um, and,
and for the most part
in very positive ways.
But Chris was also accountable.
He knew that he put himself in a very
difficult situation and he didn't blame
anybody else for it.
You know,
I talk a lot about our childhood
and my parents in my book,
but I don't blame them for his death.
Chris put himself out in
the wilderness unprepared.
I do hold them accountable
for his disappearance.
And that's a very different thing.
So one of the greatest lessons that people
can learn from Chris and kids of that
age is to be accountable and
to have that self awareness.
Because at the end, I don't
know if we have time for it, but
Chris,
um,
I put some more slides up
here simply because there's
a lot of things. That's me.
I came to the US.
It's Chris on the road.
So
just very quickly
at the end of the movie,
they show this note.
So this is the note that Chris
wrote when he knew he was dying.
I have had a happy life and thank the
Lord Goodbye and may God bless all.
So he had taken that page
out of one of his books.
And on the opposite was this excerpt
from a poem by Robinson Jeffers,
um, from Wiseman. In the bad hours,
it reads deaths, a fierce meadow Lark,
but to die.
Having made something more equal to the
centuries and muscle and bone is mostly
to shed weakness.
The mountains are dead stone that
people admire or hate their stature,
their insulin quietness.
The mountains are not soften nor troubled
and a few dead men's thoughts of the
same temper. Chris didn't do
anything without a purpose.
He didn't just randomly pull this one
page and decide to write the last words
that he's gonna write in his life
and also didn't do it for us.
He didn't do it for anybody else.
He didn't know that anybody was ever going
to find this or care. You know, w when,
when these students take pictures,
what's the first thing we all do now when
we take a picture, upload it. The first,
maybe you,
since you worked for Google,
I haven't uploaded pictures in
a long time. I'm so behind. No,
the first thing we do is we look at
the picture. We look at the picture.
Do we get the images that we're
looking for? Right? But Chris,
these pictures that people see online of
Chris, Chris never saw these pictures.
That was back in the day where you had
this thing called film on a roll and you
had to take it to the drug store and
get it developed and you don't even know
what the image is. But Chris, there aren't
five of these pictures. There's one,
he didn't take it. Let me make
sure I'm getting the right shot.
And John John writes about,
which was not a picture I have up here
cause it's too difficult for me, but he,
and I read it at the end
of my ted talk I believe,
but he writes about this photo of Chris,
the last photo that Chris takes himself
and he talks about how he's standing
beneath the High Alaska
sky and if he feels
betrayed that his body has let them
down. I'm, I'm totally John, right?
It's so beautifully and I'm,
I'm, I just, I have it here. Um,
let me just do service to this.
Just takes a minute. Sure.
So he talks about this and he,
he quotes Jeffers Palm and he says,
one of his last acts was to take a
picture of himself standing near the bus
under the High Alaska sky.
One hand holding his final
note toward the camera lens.
The other raised in a braid be
a terrific farewell. His hate,
his face is horribly and
[inaudible] almost skeletal.
That if he picked it himself and those
last difficult hours because he was so
young because he was alone because his
body had betrayed him and as well had let
him down.
It's not apparent from the photograph.
He is smiling in the picture and there
is no mistaking the look in his eyes.
Chris McCandless was at peace.
Serena's a monk gone to God.
That picture that John's talking
about, it's not. This one
is both the hardest and the most
wonderful picture for me to look at.
It's a good pain. I call it because
I see he's dying. He skeletal,
but he does have this genuine
smile and there's one shot.
He didn't take a bunch hoping that,
oh, am I going to get it right?
Am I going to put the right thing across?
He's not thinking about anybody else.
That's just pure emotion coming out of
him and it's real and it's genuine and it
happens to be because of his faith.
But
for any of us,
we live
a young number of years or whether we
live into our eighties and nineties to
have that piece at the end of our life.
Whenever that time comes to me,
that's what it's all about to,
to be at peace with the past you've chosen
in life and the way you've lived your
life,
what the purpose of your life was.
And although Chris Chris's life was short
and although he was so devastated to
be losing his life at such a young age,
and I know this from reading his journal,
he was at peace,
not because he was dying, but because
he had lived and the way he had lived.
And to me, that's my advice for students
is, you know, use those journals,
figure out who you are,
figure out what you want to be and what
you want to do and when that day comes
for you and it's going
to come for all of us.
Unless you guys at Google here figure
out, I mean, it'd be, might be common,
I'm sure you're working on it better find
us to some other planets because it's
getting a little crowded. Um, talk to you
on about, yeah, we talked a lot about it,
but, um, but that's my point.
Do you see any of Chrysalis
traits and your children?
Well, yes. So, um,
so Heather isn't biologically my child.
I adopted her.
MMM.
So as far as traits, if you mean light
have trials down biologically? Um,
Christiana, my youngest,
she is named after Chris.
Um, she has down syndrome. Doesn't matter.
Nothing is gonna stop this kid.
Things that remind me
of Chris and her are,
why can't I go climb the hundred foot
oak tree to play with the raccoons?
I don't understand why that's a problem.
I mean,
but there's also just this purity in her,
you know, obviously she doesn't know,
have,
um,
I dunno, she's only 11. I guess we'll see
what, but you know, it's, it's, I mean,
her deep thoughts right now
are about princesses, you know?
Um,
but
there's a light and appearance and
her that, that I definitely recognize.
Yeah.
Okay.
Three. Cool. Anybody else?
No. Did I talk so much that I
answered all of your questions? Sure.
I'll ask you a final one then
we can go to a book signing.
Are you guys going straight to like a
conference room to figure out this whole
issue after this?
We've got it booked.
How to populate good influences
coming into people's pages.
This is one, you know, you and I have
talked about a little bit, but um, uh,
when I went and visited the bus in 2012,
um,
there was some supplies and things and,
and,
and notes and journals that people
leave behind for future visitors.
And what was amazing when I visited
was there was a, in a plastic bag,
one of Koreans journals,
and I think it's the one that you would
take in with you when you first visited
the bus and you'd left it there for
people, I think to write in. And uh,
getting into the bus is not easy.
It's 40 mile round trip.
You have to cross two rivers. It's the
middle of the mosquitoes are insane.
Um, and you know, I
remember we'd gotten there,
we'd done a 20 mile day
that day to get to the bus.
And the first thing that I see on the
cover of this journal is a Buddhist quote
that said, there was no way to
happiness. Happiness is the way.
And it occurred to me that I'd taken
this journey to find something.
At this bus as did by the graffiti. There
are hundreds, maybe thousands of people,
um, all seeking something. But this
quote talks about it being within us.
Can you talk about it all that has
resonated with you and in your life?
That's it. Self awareness. If you
don't get away from that noises,
society sometimes, and you don't
have that self awareness. I mean,
it breaks right down to kids going to
college or they don't go to college.
They go into a career or they're
doing it they want to do,
or they're doing what
they were told to do.
Are they following their own path or are
they following a path that was laid out
for them?
It's not just academics,
it's also socially. You know, it.
All of these influences that are all
over the internet are determining these
paths and these choices that
we all make all the time
and
the kids are watching it around.
We'll cluster Corinne, thank you.